- Why hasn't Jimmy Kimmel gotten p****?
Is he gay?
- No, no.
He hasn't had excess good p****.
(upbeat piano music)
- Today we are guessing
which celeb tweets are real
and which ones are fake.
- I'm not on Twitter really,
so I think I'm gonna be bad.
- I don't tweet much.
- I am pretty confident.
I took a social media
class and they forced us...
- That's a class?
- Yeah, it was social media journalism.
- I actually don't follow that
many celebrities on Twitter,
so I am very nervous that I'm
gonna get most of these wrong.
- Honestly, Despacito
blew up because of me.
Justin Bieber.
I don't know if this is real or not,
but I could totally picture
Justin Bieber saying that.
- Yeah, but I also know
that Despacito music video
had like two billion
views before Justin Bieber
got onto the song.
- Which would just only confirm
that it's a stupid thing to say.
- Yup, he said it.
- You think that's for sure a tweet?
- I honestly almost
remember him saying that.
- I'm gonna say that's fake.
- Yeah, me too.
- Just because I desperately
need it to be fake.
- I feel like...
(loud beep)
Yeah, okay, I would've heard
from the lack of mutiny.
- He may not have tweeted
it, but he said it.
He said it.
I would like to extend
my best wishes to all,
even the haters and losers,
on this special date, September 11th.
Donald Trump.
- That cannot be real.
- Which is why I say it's real.
- Ugh!
- This one is absolutely a real tweet.
Let's all take a minute
to really let that set in.
- I'm gonna say this is false.
- [Woman] It's real.
(loud ding)
- Holy shit!
He said nothing...
Wow.
Here's my new strategy.
I'm just gonna go against my gut.
If I think it's true,
it is absolutely false.
- What's going on with my career?
Cher.
- What's going on?
(woman laughs)
- And there's no space?
- No, she didn't say that.
- This is a real Cher tweet.
I do feel pretty quickly this is real.
- There's no space in
between the my and career.
- Mycareer.
This word, mycareer.
- Career.
- Mycareer.
- Curry.
- So, I'm gonna go with real.
- [Woman] It's real.
- (screams) yeah, bitch!
See, yes, go against your gut.
- Oh you can read this one.
- [Man with glasses] Suck my
d*** you punk, get a TV deal
and then talk to me, amateur.
Charlie Sheen.
- This does seem like
something he would say.
I know that he had the whole
big public meltdown, right?
- I could see this being
a tweet if it had an at.
I'm going fake.
- I'm going true.
Are you going fake only
because I'm going true?
- Mhmm.
- I think it's real
(loud beep)
- [Woman] It's fake.
- [Woman] Does anyone think
global warming is a good thing?
I love Lady Gaga. I think she's
a really interesting artist.
Britney Spears.
- Britney fucking Spears on the internet
is my favorite thing.
- Did you combine two tweets by accident.
- I hope she didn't say this.
- I'm sure this is real.
- I'm sure too.
That's the problem.
- Have you seen her twirling videos?
- No.
- She does like runway videos
just like outfits of the day,
but has someone film her
and then she like walks
with the camera and twirls.
- I'm gonna go with real.
- This tweet is real.
(loud ding)
- [Woman] It is real.
- [Man] Mmm.
- [Man with glasses] Jimmy
Kimmel, put yourself in my shoes.
Oh no, that means you would have gotten
too much good p**** in your life.
Kanye West.
- This seems so obviously
real that I'm actually worried
it's a decoy, but I'm
gonna say this is real
that Kanye did say this.
- [Woman] It's real.
(loud ding)
- (screams) Of course it is.
Why?
I hate that guy.
- [Woman] Do ants have dicks?
Kourtney Kardashian.
- I mean, a question is old as time.
- It's kind of a great question.
- I don't know.
The Kardashians are tough for me.
- I want to say this is false,
so I'm gonna say true.
- I feel like this is
something Khloe would tweet.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna guess that it's not real.
- [Woman] It's real.
(loud ding)
- I'm glad Kourtney
Kardashian, of all people,
put up that question into the universe
'cause I never would've thought of it.
- [Man] Ugh, never going
to a Ryan Gosling movie
in a theater again.
Apparently, masturbating in the back row
is still considered inappropriate.
Anna Kendrick.
- Yeah, so I actually do follow
Anna Kendrick on Twitter.
And she's hilarious.
- Okay.
- The only thing is this
feels like it's almost going
a little too far.
- Yeah.
- I think that's real.
She's funny, she's charming.
- I'm gonna go with real too
because I want to say it's fake.
- I think I've seen this tweet before.
- Yeah, me too.
- Bless her heart.
(loud ding)
She's just like
- It's great.
- One of us.
And she doesn't care to hide it.
- Yeah, and she's letting us
know that we can't do that.
I can stop that habit now.
- Okay boys, what's your ball size?
Nicki Minaj.
I feel like Nicki would say this.
I don't think she just outright say this.
- I like her.
- I'm gonna say this is false.
- I'm saying it's true.
- I don't know.
I don't know about this one.
I'm gonna say, just for fun,
I'm gonna say yes, it's real.
- I say it's fake though.
- Yeah.
- [Woman] It's real.
(loud ding)
- What!
Oh okay.
- We got most of them right.
- Yeah, we did.
- I would say that makes
us Twitter experts.
- My social media class did nothing.
- I feel pretty good about
this Buzzfeed competition.
I think it has really enhanced my career.
(both laugh)
(upbeat piano music)